So, yeah, so next time we're
going to dive into algorithms and
talk about temporal difference learning,
so why don't we just sort of summarize
the philosophical stuff that
we talked about just now.
>> Okay.
>> So what have we learned?
>> So,
I think we learned a bunch of stuff, but
we really learned three
classes of things.
We learned sort of what
reinforcement learning is.
>> All right,
that's one class of things.
>> Yeah, and as you wrote up there, we
realize RL is about agents interacting
with environments and getting rewards
and figuring out what the world is.
And by the way, as a part of that,
we learned just how frustrating it is
to actually do reinforcement learning
rather than just solving an MDP.
>> I agree with that.
>> Okay, the second thing we learned or
we talked about was a description of
what a policy is and the different
ways you might go around solving these
RL problems and evaluating them.
What does it mean to have a good policy?
And then the third class
of things that we learned
was about evaluating learners.
And we realized that there's lots of
different ways to evaluate learners just
like there's lots of different ways
to evaluate policies and plans.
You can talk about truncating them or
doing things that are infinite.
We can talk about whether
a learning is fast,
whether a learner is efficient
in a different sense like with
sample complexity whether it
actually returns good values.
If you think about it just in terms of
it's output or how it got to its output.
>> Right.
And so
we're going to make some choices so that
we have concrete algorithms that we can
present and
analyses that we can present.
But it's worth keeping in mind that some
of these things are kind of arbitrary.
I mean, they're justified.
But there's other things that
would also be justified.
>> That seems fair in
machine learning All right,
well that all make sense to me Michael.
So, I guess we'll continue
this conversation next week.
>> Sounds good.
>> All right, have a good day.